hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen häufig zu einem neuen video
vor ein paar wochen schon was ein
whatsapp hochgeladen und viele wollten
dass ich das noch mal machen warum redet
so komisch jetzt wegen habe ich mir mal
wieder vier leute aus meiner
kontaktliste whatsup rausgesucht und
dazu auch vier songs sagen ich zeige
euch jetzt mal kurzen ausschnitt vom
ersten track ich glaube jetzt wirklich
jeder worum es in dem song geht das lied
heißt oben und ist von mein schiff
wie auch immer die fans gesprochen wird
in dem song die zeit darum dass sie auf
irgendeinem typen steht und totalen
verliebten ihn und dann nebenbei auch
noch total heidel gesagt keine ahnung
worum es in dem song geht in dem song
sagt die sängerin ich sehr offen und ich
meine normale youtuber würden jetzt
leicht erstmal so in die kommunikation
reingehen und erstmals eine gewisse
einleitung schreiben stattdessen mache
ich direkt auf den punkt gebracht klappt
das ganze übrig bei meinem kumpel umit
gemacht und seine antwort darauf war
dann sehr nice aber wir machen wir
weiter ich habe mich dabei niedrig
gehalten und dann geschrieben und omid
antwort darauf war dann hört sich gut an
ich bin dann halt weiter die losgegangen
und habe dann halt die nächste passage
geschrieben
und die trolle tief er hat da glaube ich
schon herausgefunden dass mozart rang
war und dachte dass ich ihn mit
haftbefehl kranke aber weiter im
programm des kontextes 13 37
mit ziemlich verarschen omid 360
und wenn eine junge einem anderen jungen
so eine nachricht schreibt von wegen
baby bolt weiß ich sagte sie doch
tausendmal denkt man halt nicht jeder
normale mensch so was antworten würde
wie bist du zum komplett bescheuert
stattdessen schreibt omid nicht an die
wand muss ich glaube ich nichts mehr zu
sagen
impact herz bewerten und kommentieren
nicht vergessen
vega luka macht das bei leuten die
keinen plan von youtube haben ja also
bei der ersten person hat der franken
auf jeden fall schon mal nicht geklappt
des weiteren dass es heute geht heißt
ich bin der boss von knox wort hier mal
ein kleiner ausschnitt die lyrics habe
ich diesmal an meinen manager ilja
geschickt was ist passiert ist wirklich
eine ganz normale reaktion würde ich
sagen also ihr jetzt wirklich der hat
darauf reagiert der die stadt sich aber
bestimmt ich bin der ball ist einfach
passiert finde ich gut
und halt die fresse denn direkt zu
schreiben obwohl diese person heimlich
zitat geht natürlich so ein bisschen zu
weit deswegen hat er dann natürlich auch
richtig reagiert und falls ihr euch
denkt luca warum schreibst du denn
irgendwie ich bin der boss halt die
fresse lenkungsausschuss sind die lyrics
darum geht es in dem lied aber wir
machen mal weiter mit den lyrics mann
bin ich jetzt im video
da hat er ja wohl wirklich schon
herausgefunden dass es sich hierbei um
ein whatsapp renngerät weil ich glaube
jeder hat er meinen vorherigen teilen
schon gesehen allerdings hat sich luca
davon nicht beeindrucken lassen und
natürlich weiterhin druck auf mit den
songtexten gemacht ich würde gerne meine
schwester tanja grüßen alles klar er
wahrscheinlich bin ich eine große
plattform ich hab dann weiter mit den
lyrics gemacht und ihr so ein bisschen
meine positionen klargestellt
seine antwort darauf war allerdings ein
insta heißt aho eeg wie spricht man das
aus dem ganzen noch einen versuch
gegeben und geschrieben
als antwort darauf war allerdings sein
herz also da ist der rote blätter aus
schief gegangen
beim dritten lied handelt es sich um den
song paylife von sven strange ihr mann
ganz kleiner ausschnitt
ich denke jetzt weiß jeder worum es in
dem song geht diesen weg habe ich an
sebastian ecker es oft gemacht zunächst
von den beutel der mutter kommt und
seine reaktion auf diese erste passage
war aber ich dann natürlich weiter im
programm und dann freunde ist auch
dieser prank direkt schiefgegangen
geheim mit deinem whatsapp rang soll
heute einfach nicht sein aber ihr kennt
mich freuen ich lasse nicht von so was
nicht beeindruckt ich mache einfach
weiter mit das ist alles nur deinem kopf
falscher tracks apple hat einfach auf
mit eurem aufgesetzten lächeln jammern
dies hoffentlich meint er hat schon
direkt am anfang gesagt krank war und
ich wollte das ganz einfach nie zu ende
bringen deswegen ist die unterhaltung
der nachhaltigen total bescheuert
geworden ich gebe ihm viel gespür was
lieber mit uns macht ebenfalls falscher
tracks eppelein ich kenne meine grenzen
ok mit fällt nichts mehr ein
dann hab ich das ganze wirklich noch mal
aus einer gewissen passage aus dem track
auf sein ende zugestochen
muss jetzt auch ein referat halten
dritter preis schiefgegangen arbeit habe
ja noch eine vierte person geprägt bei
diesem vierten frame handelt es sich
nämlich um das lied sieben leben für
dich von maite kelly hier ein ganz
kleiner ausschnitt dieser ausschnitte
werden echt immer länger hier wollte ich
jetzt echt wissen und habe mir gedacht
okay ich mache jetzt erstmal eine
einleitung dieser einleitung bestand aus
pro bin gerade auf die wiko 600.000 euro
auf gladbach gegen barca also wir haben
das ist so ein kollege von mir mit
mittig wir haben uns auf jeden fall über
das wetter unterhalten an dieser stelle
rettet nicht freunde das ist nur
geldverlust ist sie aus erfahrung selber
schon ein paar mal gemacht und paar mal
irgendwie so 20 euro auf vor einer
gesetzen
immerhin verloren aber wir fangen jetzt
erst mal mit den leicht zu
alles alles auf rot setzen heißt wenn
man roulette spielt und der ist dann so
eine scheibe und die drähtchen das ist
so schwarz rot schwarz rote kugel
reingeschmissen man kann auf eines von
beiden sätzen als nur 50 prozent schauen
und es gibt noch eine sache dass es
irgendwie grün aber das muss ja jetzt
alles glaube ich nicht erklären übrigens
müsst ihr mal auf die zeiten achten also
die erste nachricht habe ich um halb
zwei geschrieben die letzte nachricht
kam irgendwie um halb fünf als dieser
plan ging über drei stunden oder so was
für alle ist mit wie viel spiel zu krug
und las vegas
sagt doch wieviel ja ich vorne und diese
haltung mitglieder erstreckte sich über
so lange zeit drauf geschrieben mit dem
duschen die das kabinett nächste da habe
ich wieder direkte antworten dann kam
von dem wieder eine stunde garner hat er
darauf bald beantwortet wieso erhalten
sei nicht so richtig antwortet sagt dort
junge ich arbeite und hab kein netz
hängt mir leid aber ich natürlich weiter
im programm
ich hasse und risky hast du ein euro
gesetzt ich will change equity letzte
baby und an der stelle muss ich wirklich
sagen dieser kollege von mir weiß dass
sich youtube markierung weist sie ab und
so einen scheiß machen weiß dass ich
irgendwie verdreht bin im kopf und nach
der aussage
ich darf dich echt das von ihm so was
kommt in die richtung wie luca willst
mich eigentlich verarschen des domes ist
für ein video bei stattdessen schreibt
er will morgen italiens ist die mafia
geldwäsche und so fällt die gar nichts
auf tobi zusammenfassen bei diesem 4
praise kann ich sagen dass drei schief
gegangen sind der vierte irgendwie
überhaupt nicht geklappt hat ich kann so
was einfach das was ihr vor dem video
meine damen und herren es euch gefallen
hat dass auf jeden fall mein like da und
bei ganz ganz viel like werde ich
vielleicht noch mal machen wir findet
hier einen 2d eingeblendet wenn ihr da
drauf gehen könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren wir auf jeden fall mega
chillig weil ich eigentlich tatsächlich
nur scheiße hochladen findet ihr teil 1
eingeblendet wo ich auch schon leute
gekränkt habe mit whatsapp songtexten
hat auf jeden fall besser geklappt und
schreibt jetzt für die kommentare
whatsapp wenn ihr noch dran sein danke
tschüss